[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si vous êtes sur titom vous pouvez
savoir que le nouveau jeu à la mode
c'est le peuple attend c'est quoi le pop
hits le pop et un anti stress pour
satisfaire
[Musique]
de manière générale je pense que ça
provient le plus fécond on effectue une
action motrices très répétitives et
qu'il produit un retour sensoriel quelle
agréable
[Musique]
quand vous êtes dans votre tâche vous
avez 85 % de votre attention qui est
focalisée dessus est à peu près de 15%
qu'il va s'y et qui va s'intéresser un
petit peu à toutes les pensées qui vont
défiler par exemple est ce que j'ai
nourri mon chat est ce que j ai reçus
des nouveaux emails etc
et en fait c'est penser un petit peu
parasites
vous pouvez ensuite fixé dessus et ça
peut vous détourner de votre tâche est
en fait en malaxant quelque chose on
permettait en fait assez 15 % qui
restent de flotter et d'être sur quelque
chose d'un petit peu dynamique qui va
voilà permettre à l'attention de ceux
bassier mais sans rester sur quelque
chose de fixe à bhl et j'ai vraiment à
cet effet de décentration de l'attention
de la tâche vers un stimulus qui est un
peu plus agréable mais qui permet au
final de mieux se focaliser
[Musique]
si je devais faire mon la rouste la
satisfaction se serait l'un verse des
prestations
c'est à dire que quand on est quand on
remplit un but on les a acquis c'est ok
c'est l'achèvement d'un besoin d'un
point de vue neuroscientifique on peut
assimiler les événements de satisfaction
comme une activation du système la
récompense c'est à dire votre cerveau il
va relâcher de la dopamine est ce que ça
va faire c'est que vous allez ressentir
du plaisir
[Musique]
dans la nature les choses sont
relativement symétrique nous mêmes on
est symétriquement la symétrie c'est
quelque chose qui est ancré en nous et
donc en fait quand on voit par exemple
des formes qui sont extrêmement
symétrique
on ressent du plaisir parce qu'on les
voit comme elle devrait être
et en fait si on veut se donner une idée
la sensation inverse
on devrait regarder des vidéos non
satisfaisante et donc c'est par exemple
des gens qui remplissent des des cruches
d'eau jusqu'à ce qu'elle des portes qui
finit mal et le seuil de papier et en
fait on sent un petit peu près la même
chose mais en version négatif donc pour
les mécaniste répétitif c'est exactement
pareil
c'est à dire qu'ils produisent un
mouvement parfait qui produit lui même
un objet phare parfait comme ils doivent
être
c'est comme regarder un une belle oeuvre
d'art un beau tableau même quelqu'un qui
est qui et rick est très joli à regarder
c'est plaisant de le regarder sans du
plaisir parce que c'est beau à regarder